well here we are back it's it's Monday
Monday hey man
grab Monday by the balls make it your
rabbit by the balls and twist it so it
Yelp's but it's still in your hand you
know I'm saying make Monday your [ __ ]
ever I love the Monday memes like Monday
me yeah I'm throwing money into where I
got your flying headlock get some black
coffee and go to work you [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] money in the air whoa hey man
that's where I draw the line to line I'm
just so thankful to turn off his phone
classic cowling Talon Carolyn Carolyn
Callan man I have been here a month
well you were in Buffalo I can't I can't
wait to get into what Buffalo was like
now there was a blizzard what neck
blizzard and circu SADS fire that's it
that's pretty when there's a blizzard up
there mark my our agent Justin on Monday
I saw his leaving on Wednesday on a
red-eye he goes hey man they're
expecting one of the biggest storms of
the year we might want to cancel cancel
cancel my wet how many takes any soy
torrent a lot of take it and I got a
feeling that the third I can have a
problem get around the snow good the
snow state New Yorkers to me laugh it's
now the Penguins the Penguins oh yeah
they have no problem navigating this now
it can't do that my man we're gonna free
the sound I might miss it but let's do
it yeah get there Syracuse is cool
Turkey's nah I didn't like it as much as
Buffalo but the great crowd that venue
got funny bones amazing great really
great crowd I did not cry by myself even
loan at night but then then you eat a
cheesecake factory by myself yeah yeah
you told me that actually told me all by
myself you know me oh boy after a meal
that feels so good after after a show
and then you're alone in the Cheesecake
Factory eating at night I didn't mind it
though I didn't mind he's I'm constantly
around people non-stop talking I was off
my phone yeah I did text you how
depressed I was but I was off my phone I
was just chilling and then the next
morning I took a train at the Amtrak
train everyone Syracuse there was a
spike and a buffalo my cam tracked like
don't
to train these bros like don't do it man
you know it's alright public
transportation two hours late to early
train that's fun really that's yes so
you get the Buffalo train station that's
not depressing Syracuse train station
whoa I've been I've taken trains all
over the upper northeast so I know all
about those train stations those are
well they're warm and inviting oh
there's lots of plants lots of great
restaurants I love the guy in seriously
Syracuse goes bro I will bet you any
amount of money in the world your trains
delayed tomorrow you don't know that is
I used to ride that train all the time
into Buffalo I promise you still later
like no way oh good more likes my plate
gets full [ __ ] get there two hours doing
it to our smart kids yeah so I get to
Buffalo last time I was in Buffalo I had
a cappuccino with the Buffalo Bill so
it's good to be back he's gonna be back
shows definitely went better than my
time with the Buffalo Bills but we get
to the hotel and I look at and look at
you know my brother puts all our hotels
all our stuff I think I know tell you
say that and I go oh talked it and jegos
know it's [ __ ] not has the highest
reviews on whatever and I went it
doesn't matter
ghosts don't write reviews this thing's
[ __ ] Mohammed did he's do quit being
a baby in my case me it's he's probably
right so the first time I'm there I
swear to God shows go great Thursday
night
freezing your brother was there yeah I'm
freezing I thought three people are
gonna show up
[ __ ] the coolest I've ever been oh
yeah this is a nighttime State New York
oh my god okay I don't know much about
so I get those Arctic winds Oh trip art
arctic winds they polar bears oh yeah
so I get in my hotel room I'm exhausted
been traveling all day dense not I don't
sleep great on the road different time
change ice and I swear to God I am NOT
making this up fall asleep and my closet
doors go no the hell is that
and so I'm up it's 3:00 in the morning
I'm up I'm like looking at Mike just so
you know I got a text from Brennan
saying oh and my my hotel room is
haunted in parenthesis for real for real
for real
so my closet doors open like that that's
so weird man they go it's probably the
heat cuz I blast in the heat like crazy
like by the heat open up not a big deal
tur trying to fall back to sleep and I
hear this in online it was almost like
an apartment
set up and there's gitch I hear this
footsteps in the kitchen I'm like all
right man I'm in my undies you know you
like all out of it here's all [ __ ] up
hello is this on there and I'm on the
corner you said hello in yeah I'm like
so in there like come on man no mic and
then I turned the TV on all the lights
on I'm just scared as [ __ ] state maybe
got an hour of sleep that's kind of
Terry the next day I tell Jay I'm like
dude I'm telling you this place is
haunted
he's like you the biggest [ __ ] of all
time there's nothing wrong with it all
right another fair enough allow it let
me see your place and he has a fold-out
couch off I'm sleeping on your full lap
and he goes no you're not and he goes I
snore I go I don't care I'd rather deal
snoring than ghosts you're that afraid
no that night then I do the show right
two shows back to back get to the hotel
that night I get a text from Jay at 4:00
and more holy [ __ ] something's going on
no no what the [ __ ] then we ask the
manager at the place and I'm like mean
Jay look exhausted
I I told Buffalo I'm like I swear to God
I used to be way cuter my rooms haunted
I've got no sleep I look like [ __ ] I
apologize and then I the manager goes oh
you guys are staying at the hotel at the
Lafayette are you yes he goes Oh bro
that's on the Buffalo haunted tour every
year like yeah I looked at Django you
suck man hey guys suck there's these
nice weari do some Paranormal Research
jam on bro today what though about
Buffalo a the nicest people in the world
I was so friendly to me and well cuz
they have communities that run deep the
roots run deep so my father would always
say that there anybody who came to work
for a his bank a bank he worked at from
Buffalo almost always went back and
retired and I'll do you one better blue
collared when they would go to Buffalo
to work and they were from somewhere
else at a bank and a branch said I can't
believe you sent me there stayed you
know the the real estate there's booming
it's actually when the hottest spots now
on these can really it's boom boys yeah
it's gorgeous there yeah like
everything's like great the weather's
[ __ ] terrible
sometimes looks like Bane we took off
over Gotham City but it's it's gorgeous
there and all the buildings are super
old but well-built and huge yes
architecture this right now and you know
I'm a hater some of the best food I've
ever had in my life you said that and I
thought you were joke I know no you know
what it is it's the Italian deep deep
Italian roots so the the manager forgive
his name so I Brothers love that guy but
the manager there I was like man you
should go to the cause I was like man we
love buffalo wings on the keto diet camp
buffalo wing so as long as they're not
breaded he said go go to these two spots
went literally the best wings in my life
Gabriel's hand my mouth is watering
hands down the best wings of my life but
they're also open like to 4:00 in the
morning they're serving and then this
restaurant I told Jay right when we sat
down that we our second night there I'm
tired
later on junk food best food are you
talking about to shop no no no they have
good food in general so this place it's
called mothers everyone's like yeah go
to Mother's that's where like the
Buffalo Bills and the Sabres hang out
like that's where you want to be man not
the Sabres whatever the team name bring
that up I want to see a picture of
mothers we sit down Mother's I look at
Jay I'm like count eat this place up
it's just like this old-school tween the
same owner for like 40 year old school
time home vibe they write all the menus
every day I had a rib eye Jay had the
the fillet that's and then there's a
little barrier it was freakin amazing
man to me it was so cool it's really
cool table ya know it's a restaurant hmm
so there's like a little bar then to the
left like a really nice restaurant where
they literally handwrite all the menus
damn really amazing that sounds good now
little gems you know when you have
weather like that when you have weather
like that yeah
and people are tracking on dig in the
snow to see you do some comedy yeah they
like to drink oh yeah the Rowdies crowds
ever had my huh the colder it gets in
the winter the more booze the cannabis
the same way and everybody by the end of
that show people have had about six to
twenty five drinks by my late show my
last Late Show I see a little commotion
you know I can tell you feel yeah I've
seen people turn around
see this girl stand up go you go there
you go how famous got dumped by your
boyfriend something huh and you know
they take her out
fan out husband died first night out
oh well that's what happens as a bummer
that's terrible because a fight broke
out of Mike my crowd Schaumburg Illinois
now Sean birds like trouble kiss him
it's a suburb of Chicago like downtown
shaker is no it's about a half-hour
outside all due respect to Schaumburg
great quality people I sent me a picture
of the club that place looks ridiculous
400 people
but yeah it's a no it just looks amazing
yeah it's a it's a Bell donging place
yeah is it in a mall it's it's a it's a
part of an out a large sprawl which is
part of them all but it's its own
structure and yeah it's basically
Schaumburg that I mean it's it's large
square beige buildings all the
restaurants a lot of different
restaurants Panera why are they all the
food all tastes the same
I'm not your type of place I didn't see
any houses there nobody lives in
schaberg into office buildings and
restaurants all quarters yeah it used to
be a big field and then they put a [ __ ]
onto that that's what I think I heard
the shows are great and you're sold yeah
I saw them sold out we sold out both
shows Friday still have both shows
Saturday they'll go and anyway but it
was uh it was it was it's a very when
you stay in a place like that not too
cold about 24 degrees 25 degrees yeah
but if there was a light there was a
bike shorts in it they started this
there was a whole situation and a woman
said well his girlfriend's ugly that's
why and I go all right hey man don't be
nothing worse than being I had to scold
him you see for me you know obviously
you've been doing this forever
I really had too much crowds like them
the finer kid we've got them but for me
to navigate through that this was your
first we have to there's a bit of a
milestone for you because this is your
road from being being a road pup to
being a road dog because this was your
first full week go full weekend which is
very different people don't realize
you're doing five shows six shows that's
seven new seven shows and that's how you
get good really good also dealing with
different dynamics so a few hecklers
just fine whatever navigate through that
little girl threw up had you had to stop
restart get back on track
that's all good man yesterday I embraced
that yes it is had one guy filming I saw
him like I literally was like what are
you doing and that make you crazy I'm
like what are you doing he crazy
he's like this I'm like you man with the
camera what are you doing brother
hey come on man why would you do that so
would you go in a movie theater on film
yeah he's like no I'm like then why
would you get here you [ __ ] me are you a
fan iou's I'm the biggest fan right
no you're not then you wouldn't film
take my bat he's in the line at the VIP
and he's like the last one I go dude
what are you doing filming us I don't
know I'm ever in a comedy show yet did
you not hear the announcements with
signs or it's a no film goes I don't
know what we're gonna do that footage it
was put on Facebook man show everyone I
was here I go
you don't think your picture would do
that I see no bad that [ __ ] me man
well because what they people he just
didn't know I'm gonna shoot it's all
good I said but think about what you're
working on bits that are ultimately
gonna be in a special but then I read
out of town also you have a show right
it's like getting leaked if let's say
study this is a weird comparison but
just for finances let's say Star Wars
comes out on Friday someone gets a hold
of it on the two weeks before then
plastid everywhere when you get to the
show you know what's happening yeah so
in my so you [ __ ] my guys for the
people in Portland in Boston Demetri
used to say Demetri Martin who's
hilarious amazing joke a writer and he
what the problem was that college kids
would see him and then they would tweet
his jokes and text his jokes but
especially tweet be like his one-liners
cuz he's like a one-liner yeah and I
tweeted to the neck and all the kids in
the college Theory knew they already
knew that you I the guys in front row
and you'd you know you can tell her I'm
going the story yell out I went dude you
gotta stop I said if you got five
minutes I'll give you the mic right now
coming into five minutes unless you
wanna keep going you want to keep going
now once you come up here and finish it
for me it getting kind of shut down but
it was fun though great [ __ ] time
some of the best coffee this place
called public coffee in the haunted
mayor hilly amazing you don't say dude
I'm telling you good food you know if I
got a buffalo I'm staying at the
Lafayette no no no no no no there's a
Westin I think there might be a for head
girls don't do that bro look at me man
I'm not afraid of [ __ ] and I had a
phrase spirits and I'll go there I don't
know and I and I invite them
we'll have a little talk I took my
opener was Abby's guy named Rick even do
it for like nine years it's open for a
Jim Norton mm-hmm and then he's open for
Tom Segura Dave Attell
yeah dude and he's a correction officer
at the what's the main prison there
Atticus there's a big Attica Attica
Attica was the main guy Fred
yeah really and he came in and goes shop
he said quite neck hurts I'm like I
don't know Matt all right this right
here what happen he goes I got hit with
by a bat
I go damn one of the you know guys
taking Tom hat one of the prisoners he
goes no man like a big stretch flapping
was a bat anyway
oh [ __ ] like a pigeon you know like a
with wings he was yeah man one of those
dirty are a rat with wings yeah like an
actual bat was in the prison I was
trying to school some dude this [ __ ]
demon path comes out of the sky and he
goes I just went to dodge all the way my
feet give out because I hit my back my
head on the the see man my god I'm
concussed I got death problems I was
laughing so loud you got to see him I
was laughing so uh did you hear about
the guy who this is crazy this reminds
me of the story he's in Indonesia with
his friends that he's known since he was
six years old and every year they take a
surfing trip there in the middle of the
Indian Ocean they break open a calzone
and he smells he goes that doesn't smell
good [ __ ] I'm hungry eats it bad Roma
Kelson middle of the night bad food
poisoning he's got to come up on deck
and he's got to throw up and he throws
up over the thing then he throws up
again throws up a third time and falls
overboard
where's yet he's until the Indian Ocean
okay okay
so that would be we call that chumming
the water right oh that's that's correct
so water from the water and now you fall
in okay so and that's the middle of
night now you're in the Indian Ocean
it's teeming with wildlife teeming well
that's when they get Wow I'll call from
the VIPs come up my VIPs I mean the old
shark I don't ah so much screaming and
somebody's got food poisoning so the
boat just keeps going keeps on a
chocolate is leaving okay pitch dark
we'll see you later bro we'll see you
later all this like that movie come on
about six or seven hours and
where's John huh and then then we'll
start looking with circle back around so
go ahead takes about nine hours to get
there so go ahead and and swim towards
us toward the boat you know keep
swimming in this direction or just chill
in the Chum water well he come he swims
all night and then he realizes that he's
about to pass out he's exhausted his
joshan boy he's exhausted sick so you
know it wakes him up he starts to fall
asleep and he goes and he gets hit in
the back of the head boom and he goes
what the [ __ ] the shark goes hey bro
don't sleep on the job shark
it's a seagull - seagulls cuz they
thought he was like dead meat and he
looks up like that and another secret of
those hits him in the nose it's just
feathers and blood he just got blood
everywhere this thing bit him in the
he's guy's nose is bleeding
Fabio this is great exactly like Fabio
so now he's like oh yeah but now there's
blood oh there's blood he gets bumped by
a shark a shark goes boom like cuz I'll
bump you sometimes is that night still
no this is dishes now he made the duck
now we're made to dawn dawn now we're
dawn bump he gets it's a gong time bomb
that's a great time that's the shark
just be like what we got probably a
Tigre probably ltu and yeah yeah
probably an El Tigre or a bull shark El
Toro
you got it got a tiger shark or a bull
shark el Toros it's either out or El
Tigre pick your poison
pick you that's like saying hey you
wanna get blasts in the face by a
shotgun or ak-47 right you're talking
about a couple locomotives with fins and
jaws so you got the Chevy with jaws it
kind of bumps here he uh laughs that
thing [ __ ] casually swims away
totally uninterested so he's like Riley
this thinks was like yeah [ __ ] he's like
oh okay oh no I said he came back he
gets stung by a Portuguese Man O for oh
my god yeah
just stings the [ __ ] out of them okay
please remember he's in a tease your
toes look like it's the most cheese man
it's what you just jellyfish in the
world up the old Portuguese
Manowar it looks like a jellyfish but it
has a galaxy inside of it it's like all
purple and pink I have personal
experience with it cuz been stung on the
legs when it was out of the water they
say oh don't they don't they can't sting
you out of the water
complete horseshit you know how you get
rid of them picked it up and it hit me
on the list on each other that's what
they say
it's fake I heard not to get somebody
put it on you bro just in case we see
one today and that's what they look like
they fill their bas sack with with it
air and and their tentacles can be oh I
don't know six miles long but this is my
thing
clearly that thing's poison of course it
does
neon pink with ramen why I'm into it you
don't realize now I another guy like
maybe we keep going yeah gets better
Oh me so yes done like that yeah it gets
better oh sudden he's like dealing that
oh that's on his body I go oh my he's
being tortured by a tortured now his
legs feel like they're on fire and these
tiny silver flesh-eating fish
I'm fish they're like mmm I love skin
he's like kicking yeah he's freaking out
he's in a school of him they're just
they're just chowing down peanut loves
of the sea being on laws of the sea
little silver flesh biting video so this
[ __ ] he's really successful
he runs a huge business so he goes
alright I'm gonna die he starts to
hallucinate he sees like an old like a
bunch of sailors from like the 1700s
hello maybe he's like keep swimming boy
keep swimming the Virgin Mary's like he
was Jewish to the Virgin Mary shows up
and she goes keep swimming son you're
gonna do this he goes okay okay so he
realizes he's hallucinating go crazy but
he runs a huge company so check this
[ __ ] out he goes you know what all right
we gotta break my body up into a team
left leg your name is Steve right leg
your name is Paulo and crazy yep left
arm your name is Bonnie right arm your
name is yet Jennifer now you guys were
in my front office you guys in my back
office my nostril my right nostril is
gonna be Janine she's gonna be my
Account Manager and Paula your mother
left not right nostril cuz you're gonna
be the one who who are you're gonna be
the one who's a head of operations
I'm gonna check
with you how are we doing good stuff I
got to talk to your legs Oh God uh Marie
Jennifer you're not kicking enough let's
go ahead and take those deadly breaks
down so his whole body became his office
yeah and he was checking in with the
office and they were all communicating
with each other this [ __ ] this
[ __ ]
yes yeah got eaten by God he got his
head chopped off his [ __ ] was
having so bad
he swam directly in a great white shark
mouth and white wasn't even hungry the
end he got shot by pirates right before
they get about they took his water bowl
here and shattered it's a slab damn it
took his well contributed a shot him in
the face and that's what he deserves
he made to a boat but they were pirates
they killed and the motto is story -
foth about no he this dude stayed stayed
afloat for 28 hours which people say is
pretty much impossible in the sea yeah
especially when you have food poisoning
even stone but bump by shark eaten by
silverfish and fog and storm by pork
cheek is metal in nature decks live
bombed by color seagulls [ __ ] seagull
I mean he was off that pisses me off the
most the sample 28 hours he made it they
pull him on shore of these Australians
pulled him on shore he thought he was
hallucinating again he goes oh they're
like I'm eight we gotta keep going
they angle on say he falls asleep they
give him water they feed him they get
him back on his boat that all his
friends have known him since he was six
or like it was like it was like a more
they thought he was dead I thought he
was dead they couldn't believe it
captain and he he gets his wits about
him has a couple drinks they sit there
cab puts an arm around him and they
cried for five hours straight
500 sobbed for five and a half hours
every man oh that's a [ __ ] nightmare
that's a Lester nightmare your watery
grave and because there was no doubt in
my mind I was definitely gonna die I
went out weird is we just accept it yeah
guy that's what we're doing under do
this what we're doing yeah but no you
know it like yeah yeah I know you go
under your body's gives out you going
and you you know then everything turns
black and you go night-night
well done I take my buddy um
investigators a cop and he investigated
he had to investigate a death where a
woman basically went on a cruise wrote
all these letters
all these poems about dying and then put
a knapsack on mellow night middle of the
night on a cruise filled it with weights
and cotton cuffed her hands and her feet
Jesus yes the dedication oh yeah and
jumped overboard where and she figured
out also how crazy is this this is
[ __ ] nuts she figured out where it
was the deepest figured out that there
would be a certain time the boat was
passing over like where the water would
be too much what is wrong with her she
just wanted some don't worry [ __ ] I know
it is she wanted to go away and never be
found again that is so done she and my
friend wrote out red halt read all her
letters are they any good
they were like um like these weird kind
of like poetic stories of dark [ __ ] you
think and she just jumped overboard she
was about 53 or something God yeah it's
very strange and yeah I wonder when
you're in a situation like that where
you either fight and I know you're
hallucinating you keep fighting or they
just give up me like damn that's how it
goes down
god I bet you're just like I can't
believe this is how to answer my buddy
what up crock of [ __ ] and yeah I bet
your thing about how I was even gonna go
oh can you believe that I was gonna go
I'd say get on a plane here we [ __ ]
are I'll go to Dave's bachelor party get
balls deep in these Siberian horrors but
instead I cancel that and I'm here yeah
and now I get this goddamn jellyfish
tied around my tentacles you know I'm
saying yeah turn around my testicles we
just have tentacles around my pencils
that's a good day that's three times you
know what tentacles on your testicles
tentacles on your testicles to get it
you know so so who's married to
Beyonce's mother
Beyonce yeah Knowles winner Knowles yeah
Tina knows her husband who was my acting
teacher for many many years
oh really yeah wonderful guy sure did
Beyonce on the show B and what's that
you'd be on til I should talk to her
taking an aspic for me from yeah Richard
Lawson Richard Lawson when he was a soap
star was there is a stud stud a medic in
Vietnam two tours
one of the more simin of the most thing
one of the most impressive man I've ever
met
actually those kids are a real [ __ ]
man
I mean a real man okay don't say and and
[ __ ] what was I was it was this
was the story he battled a bunch of
jellyfish oh yeah he was a plane crash
the plane that went down in LaGuardia it
didn't hit the way went right into the
Hudson right right and 21 people died or
something like that and he hit the water
he was in his seat the water the plane
broke apart now think about this the
plane breaks in half you're in the water
okay and you're in a seat with your
seatbelt on okay yeah there you go
and he hits the water he's like this
he's knocked out under water he looks
over he sees everything everybody's
under water you were just on a plane and
the waters like it's freezing and you
know you got to know him like two tours
of Vietnam like just a bad act like just
a guy who was a medic and driver plus
survivor and also also when he would
teach class from 7 to 12 at night 1 to a
student raised his hand said you know
I've been in this class for five years
I've never seen you yawn once and he
said yeah yeah that crazy and he goes I
don't I don't say I don't suffer from
fatigue because I don't focus on the
fatigue you know what he learned was
that in Vietnam he would see American
soldiers shot and they would go into
shock and he would see Vietcong guys
gave gravely injured and they never went
into shock and he said now what's going
on well he said we'd sight it to the
base he said what Americans we are we
have a culture that focuses on ourselves
so the American would look at the oh my
god I've been shot and focus on the
wound
the Vietcong would always focus out
there so they thought of themselves on a
leaf on a big tree Americans are taught
to wear the tree yeah we still won and
so there was a mindset right so so he he
never forgot that and he kind of
practiced Buddhism and all that stuff
the idea of of studying of putting
yourself putting take being outside of
your body and and and putting your
attention out there and never on
yourself yeah so under the water he said
he was he doesn't have water and he he
he comes to he goes what the [ __ ]
pulls off a seat belt tries to like
rescue some he's like I can't do this he
just [ __ ] swims to the surface and he
gets up in there and here's the problem
this is jet fuel on the water so he
starts inhaling jet fuel so he starts to
like he can't breathe he can't like his
body goes into shock
he scales the wall I think there was a
wall here trying one would enjoy yeah
and it's cold he climbs up somehow gets
himself on like the tarmac and he's
sitting there like and a dude shows up
he's like hey man I got you I got you
and he's like can't breathe and the guy
goes oh [ __ ] yo man you're on that soap
opera oh what's that smell that was
being recognized as he's [ __ ] you
know as people and it was a crazy story
did you read like the most [ __ ] epic
survivals of all time no I'm just cuz
you hit me with the bat story and I'm
like you know I got one for ya yeah my
guy just got hit by a bad old one-upper
over here at Jesus Christ no just got
hit by bad he's good now [ __ ] he's great
now though yeah it's so scary
like that that guy maybe Daniel Perlman
not not the pearl guy I forget his name
but he got captured by Isis or al-qaeda
and there's a whole documentary on HBO
it's [ __ ] brilliant seen it but he
gets captured by al-qaeda any lay-up
they have everyone there and it's like
12 Americans and you know he awfully got
executed he's one of the famous one
where they severed his head but they
said in that time it was like you know
you're getting rash and you know you're
hitting like a grain of rice to eat and
stuff like that they said everyone else
is like we're dead man we're dead and
he's like nah nah man we're not well we
got to do his work as a team we got each
other you know and they were pulling
people by three or five out and then
mocking execution so you never knew
you're gonna die so you going crazy all
the time they said he was just positive
rallied the troops and then they started
negotiating ago she ating getting people
out and so like there was like 15 no
down to 10 then it went down to 5 and he
was like we're good man but they Daniel
Pearl daddy / that he was like we're
good man they were like he was so
positive and then he would hide stuff in
his pocket somehow well he found some
way where he could get these like
mangoes or some [ __ ] and he didn't eat
him he gave them to everyone else they
would do himself and then during when
the Mach 2 executions you know he's like
I'll be right back this they're just
trying to go and get to they'll say
really did it
they did even then just a monster I
believe but I just think at that time a
what's crazy to me is a time it's the
darkest hour man yeah that's still
another you are but he's still like nah
[ __ ] that man we're not going out like
this we're not doing that they always
say that's when you know who you are
right in your darkest hour how do you
behave like how are you gonna behave
it's it's always what a badass yeah you
talk about a guy a camera man a a
journalist who went on the front lines
you gotta be bass already it's right and
he's done it three times and who's cop
before and still went back yep
it's nots amazing but just a real badass
you know it reminds me of when I was in
that haunted hotel hey man come on
Brennan I get told no brother was
freaking out no no it's all your Beyonce
Knowles
no dad you know I was in there oh god
now I believe I got scared I was like
we're gonna get through this and now
here we are I said I believe they found
the guy who beheaded they even though he
was under a hood CIA I think they found
him and I think he was he's been put to
rest himself they did work yeah they did
as they say they did he's out there in
Guantanamo or he's been he's been put to
rest ah they take care of it yeah we'll
take you you don't want to get the
British SAS and the and the American
Delta Force etc CIA after you know find
you're gonna find you find you of Cour
they're gonna find everything yeah I am
yeah that's what blows my mind [ __ ]
badass I'll tell you i text i text you
this yesterday went not that but
nothing's wrong with buffalo i just have
a different lifestyle that I'm
accustomed to here I could you know
Buffalo was amazing and all that but
when you're out there and you in
Syracuse you're on the train stuff like
that in your Buffalo and turkeys for a
while then get back to LA like we take
it for granted when you get used to
something you know if you drive a car
you used to the car if you you know if
you have a hot girlfriend I can show you
someone who's sick of [ __ ] beyonce
knowles names jay-z cheat on so you
always get used to it you know yeah step
back so when you go out on the road from
doing that stuff and come back as soon
as I got in my in my car did hit the
highway like oh my god yeah it's I'm
never leaving yeah it's the best home
it's the best well it's 73 73 degrees
and and bright sunshine I mean is is
everything on fire yeah
we'll get through this we'll figure this
out yeah yeah it's all good as always
can get through the fire I mean [ __ ]
happens and it's like it's all good baby
that's not a shining I got the beach I
heard I heard they think bumps I did
those fires I've heard that yes it was a
homeless encounter which is why I always
say we have to get a kill you got they
don't have a car just not a look I'm
sure some are very nice people for all
hobos just need simply need to die I'm
sorry guys yeah I'm not even trying to
be a dish that's you Bochy and I've
really on this one no especially if they
look cold we killing yeah but but we do
it humane Lee no you just kind of yeah
throw jellyfish don't ya or just a
high-powered rifle but you know what I
mean I mean just because we can't have
fires like listen you've seen the movie
the purge I agree with that well I think
you just go after the bum that's once a
year just all bum fast
we call it pump fest and just it's free
reign you have a home nope dick dude you
guys ready to go on a bum run and wait
but we have teams we have like cool
t-shirts now oh no go
it's hobo no go today guys hobo no go
the bum down we're gonna called the bum
down the bum down so [ __ ] I'm down
ahh dude why'd we do just this we just
[ __ ] lost oh my bad that's right a
bad some homeless guy loose the park
it's like [ __ ] you guys man I've been a
longtime listener
you know I make very little money but
the money I make I have a [ __ ] cell
phone
and I listen to podcast passed the time
and [ __ ] you time I was sitting eating
breakfast in New York City and the guy
comes in a handsome guy and look like a
biker and he's like he's like I'll get
the same thing I'll get that
scrambled eggs please and bacon would be
great and gether totin that'd be great
thank you so much man although this is
perfect I'd love a spray you know again
making espresso was gonna get a coffee
but let's me you know I can let's make
it both thanks man appreciate her he's a
great guy mustache kinda handsome guy
was like that handsome young kind of you
know 40 cent maybe maybe forty even
handsome and babe bro
kind of a strapping young man have a
conversation with him talking he's
eating basically the same thing I mean
and so as I go up Dean be eating the
same kind of food and I said I said what
do you do I'm an actor you [ __ ]
recognize you
la I lived in that way for a long time I
came out here about eight months ago had
a motorcycle accident and I was like
[ __ ] it and just came out I go ok
motorcycle accident you ride a bike
because I did I did yeah and he sounds
good good good on you man how's that I
was so acting at that tough gig and
stand-up and great and I said what are
you doing cuz you know don't laugh but I
am I I set out piece of cardboard and I
basically Panhandle because they make an
average of 57 dollars a day I've
averaged it out don't laugh but I yeah
and then it says [ __ ] thing was so
normal but I was I was like now I gotta
fight it might be crazy look crazy I go
I go but you had the motorcycle accident
what what did you do that was it that
was it for me I was here they go
but but it wasn't it because I go well
why didn't you just you know I don't
know fix the bike I couldn't my surprise
I was finished oh I wish it was snap I
know hey don't laugh but don't laugh I
was like you just went to the dark side
brother haloo okay so we're not able to
maintain this mood sometimes you're not
able to maintain no it's just a phase
that yes is the phase the crazy is when
you go from one spectrum to the other
that's when you know people are crazy
dark quick I've dated thrown like that
dark quickie it's like a Jeffrey Tambor
the great story about how to play crazy
he's talking a guy what do you do
there's nothing right now but I plan on
killing the president
oh well you said that very
matter-of-fact way yeah
dude how about I get home I hate
sleeping Oh does the way I get home like
I can't wait
well my son Tiger went ah young got rest
that's fantastic well guess what
now I'm scared of the dark and spiders I
think they're all in my room so I'm I
can see my crib anymore and I know you
have one of those big tall cribs that
I'm so it's not to be able to get out
but check this I got the shop I let him
down he goes would like a [ __ ] Navy
SEAL right over that thing yep lands on
his feet goes to the door what are you
guys doing down here
yeah what's cracking down here huh just
like an octopus out of a fish dude
dude I want some
she's just going through this I was
reading about it all last night no sleep
where he's just having like anxiety
where you leave him or you know he's
scared of something something's
triggered that though he doesn't wanna
be by himself I get night terrors yeah
yeah exactly they have night time but he
has nothing like nothing really scares
I'm like we joke not joke around but
like there's these spiders but he finds
him cool we were on this walk there's
this huge spire come big jack but we're
never scared of him but I think there's
spiders in his room he doesn't watch
anything scare out on watch anything
scary but so he eat that did lay down on
my bed and sit there at 7:30 so I mean I
just you can't have the TV on and
there's no phone so I just sat there
staying at the wall while he snored like
a baby warthog then a final I fell
asleep round snoring oh my god he storms
like a warthog like a baby warthog and
there's no [ __ ] kid he's so cute but
then you know I'm sleeping me my girl
asleep and he's in the middle and he
likes to move around like his dad a lot
he likes them really move around but he
slaps think of penguin he's slapping him
she slapped me all night I got no sleep
and at 4:00 in the morning thought ah
[ __ ] it everyone get up
I'm starts jumping on the bed like this
is a good time and then I just grabbed
like no we're not doing that I hold him
there and he's like making noise more
like let's just try to fall asleep
finally fell asleep but it was a beast
man that's a beast
I said yeah your kids are not my son
woke me up from a nap I I just I wake up
and I just feel a little touch on my arm
he's standing in front of me and he's
waving like this he's so [ __ ] cute
climbs right up on me starts telling me
about his dream and it's a long one it's
a long one dude the dream there's a
ghost but I killed it with salt why did
why do have ghost died from salt I was
like there's no I don't know there's
gold there in this they're snails and
they're easy to kill any more nail
family not very scared any more easy
snails in salt won't like salt and
ghosts let's move on let's definitely
move on yeah I finally after a half hour
ago okay we're gonna stop talking about
the dream now cuz he started making
should you find go hey I need to shut
the [ __ ] up and you should go to sleep
you know because I'm gonna duct-tape
your mouth okay I don't put salt all
over your face and I started going
thank you everyone go so real and all
your dreams are gonna come true do you
see the fights I did
so the yeah the UFC fights but then also
Billy Joe Saunders fought David Lemieux
which is amazing boxing match and I
asked the guys at the helium I don't I
make zero demands I'm the easiest comic
come through there I say if there's
fights on can you put them on I was
hoping I could have HBO cuz the Lemieux
Billy Joe Saunders fight was on HBO and
then obviously the UFC was on Fox so all
the UFC ones for the most part and then
just it missed the Billy Joe Saunders
one but I saw it last night a little bit
of it took my son decide to be LeBron
James with the babies but the bots for
Billy Joe Saunders Jenna didn't watch
soft cover real quick but Billy Joe
Saunders undefeated things 27 I know he
had a fight like the biggest competition
but he does he always steps up and let
me use a real I mean he destroyed them
you see eight outclassed them Wow they
think the winner that if Canelo triple G
for whatever reason can't come an
agreement so I Billy Joe Saunders will
fight triple G really yep triple G did
we just thought of you
he stopped with a body shot right yeah
but he just used a run smack of them
with it Lemieux is amazing watch when he
fights a really like technical box or
with good footwork who has a jab Ethan a
lot of trouble at the very very highest
level other than that he's a monster
hits like a Mack truck him verse Cannell
is a great fight since he lost but I
won't get it but that's the fight Tim
when I was watching the UFC I thought I
had a thought I was like you know I
never see a double jab in in MMA really
and then I saw a guy double jab and
double like it depends yeah guys but
usually that's why is that
is it not as effective like we counted
with the right hand but if it's a
high-level boxer see double jab yeah JDS
who uses double jazz steep a use a
double jab it's a high level guys will
use it just depends I was like I worry
about the camp counter but I was
watching my parry like my parents got
great head movement like he's really
hard to hit like he just hands down and
just moving that head I'm like big fan
man I was bummed out he lost sight i he
has star written all over me you know
some people think he's a little bit too
much but especially at 170
that kid has star written all over yeah
tell you the fight to make Mike Perry
and there's something Chin's I might
marry Bobby Lawler oh I was gonna say
Korea cowington no no you can't do that
because Connie times number three needs
gone in win streak
you knew Kobe Cummington versus dos
Anjos the hen fight to Mayo that's what
he says woodleigh's alcohol well would
Lee's out for a while with the shoulder
surgery so dos Anjos you know I don't
know if you want to wait seven months if
I'm dos Santos I wait welterweights
murderers row I would wait because who
knows when you get the opportunity and
to be honest I think he can beat Woodley
now he's probably another dog he matches
up great with the same dos Anjos dos
Santos yeah you're saying throw Sancho
yeah he did you're saying he could be
Woodling yes yes I bet he'd be an
underdog but you know he [ __ ] looked
amazing and Robbie like at the press
conference is so funny he's just you've
just no excuses excuses just sit there
on man I just better man tonight just a
lot a lot of punches yeah I mean he just
got a little bit you just you know
thought the best dos Anjos right yeah
but you know it's a matter to of you
know Robbie Lawler has a lot of miles on
and dos and Joe Santos at 170 you know
he's not making that huge weight cut
he's a world champion at 55 yeah now
he's at 7 he feels good he's marking
everybody now any you know I'd be his
weight class
it was boxing guys right and I cannot
give us kind of credit jason Perillo
who's cyborgs Michael Bisping BJ Penn
there's something going on here when
other people in Southern California
figure it out
and when the world's gonna figure out
he's the best best striking coach in the
world he's gonna be a lot more busy but
I don't think he wants to be that busy
but you don't hear about him you know
why he's not in the back shouting and
his teachers demise oh no he's a
professional yeah and he and he works
out Ruka Jim he's the best striking
coach in the world
and you only takes certain people and
then he just took those and just look at
dos ángeles we get those Angeles
striking like it's Robbie Lawler
promoting morning I'm coming for you how
about it's a private gym at Ruka you're
not getting in there you're not seeing
some old actors up and they're trying to
be tough don't wait hey leave me what
that's trick
june frank grillo hey hey this ain't
wild corn west and the same iron jim
where the oldies are they're living out
the old glory days look at Jason Pirela
there is Wow
in fact if if I was young if I was
younger you'd be right with him that
would be the guy if I'm a young fire and
listen this part look at this [ __ ]
spear to figure it out I was stable but
it's not even that because it is stable
we got a look at what his stable has
done since since they're off with him
yes okay we get cyborg shrunken she's
not such she doesn't fight like so
berserk anymore she's controlled calm
cool she's gonna outsmart yeah
BJ Jesus Christ BJ Penn you know he is
boxing's better but he's off yet than an
end of his road but we kept Michael
Bisping finally a world champion yeah
he's a pearl oh yeah and then look at
dos Santos now he's for a title shot the
guy's a straight-up mastermind but you
don't hear him doing enemies don't hear
I'm talking about game plans you don't
hear any of that stuff I was watching a
Robbie Lawler take those low like like
front of your shin kids kicks like those
warm-up I know he's so he's so rugged
he's so rugged and tough as they come
it's tough there's team all calmness
first team all toughness I mean and I
was well I say all those guys that level
of tough and then there's that little
extra thing it's him Dan
come on then I'm getting old dan dan
okay
strong [ __ ] face the squad Henderson yes
Dan Anderson like certain guys that are
like made of wood it puts steep in that
category yep they're made a wood there's
a different thing but you have favored
in the yes you're 100% your I favor and
but again like with Robbie fighting
since he was 17 years old you know it
it's gotta it's gotta you you've always
said this it's just there there is
always a point where if all the time was
a yeah it's been fun yeah you've beat a
lot of odds do you think he's there
though because he went the distance it
was a hell of a fight but again more
lost every round he lost every round he
did not win one round he wasn't really
in the fight yeah he's still top five
guy who knows got
I'm knowing that's tell Robbie Lawler to
retire there's still a lot of fight left
him if he wants it him beat
tell me guys I think he'd give a lot of
these young guys all he can handle
inverse Mike Perry you know that's a
tough fight it's a great fight and I
don't know if you know Mike praise
coming off a loss he wasn't really
ranked that high to begin with so know
if Robbie wants to do that but that's a
[ __ ] fight man
then how about Ricardo Lamas talk about
the getting the brawl end of the stick
so a little background on that B so he's
supposed to fight Jose Aldo
although gets yeah they pull although
although gets you know all he gets the
title fight yeah he it's max Holloway
Lamas really doesn't have opponent the
human opponent late they give him this
kid who's miss wait a few times were
they supposed to meet was he gonna meet
I'll do at 55 or he's gonna be at 45 45
okay yeah so you know they pull although
they're like man we don't know what
we're gonna do with you
we're gonna reschedule for this then
they give him this kid on two-week
notice something short notice you know
he's had some weight problems he they
Emmett misses wait yeah they still fight
yeah and then you get flat one the left
hoods I'm nasty and the see his head hit
when he got hit and its head I like out
it's a walk behind us like out cool I
just walked away just a bummer yeah man
that's the game though innit that's the
goddamn game it really is the game the
toughest the tough you always fall such
a freaking bone room and the majority
other fights I didn't really recognize
the names to be completely honest with
you I mean Glover oh yeah that was great
clover man wrestling he's a beast rest
Bob and if you uses his wrestling some
in grappling more you know that he's
ranked out what numbers here in the
world so you got gusts in you got a
özdemir who he would destroy Oh straight
you would he would that's saying a lot
the awful matchup right is that right oh
because of his wrestling cuz those
mirrors striking is Holly as long as he
can avoid you know the initial pop for
most American gets a hold of me look
what he did uh you know Misha he just
did and he gets to holding he's strong
as balls yeah jimbros DC's a fun fight I
don't know if we'll ever get there but
him force DC is a very very fun fight
matchup
yeah what just these match up is great
you cheese up straight up our punter he
can wrestle his ass off as a black belt
on the ground yeah but what his
wrestling Abu Dhabi world champion yeah
but he's also dealing with DC's
wrestling really she's never been out
wrestled except for by you know yeah
every time they fought he got out
wrestled by yeah yeah but he's a much
better grappler in DC it's a different
gaze yes oh my god world he's world
class by saying Abu Dhabi I know but
JC's two-time Olympian in wrestling
being so there's wrestling which starts
on her feet and then it goes to the
ground yeah yeah Glover is world class
on the ground yeah DC's not his job to
wrestle yes yes so there's glass grapple
rock classic where your Abu Dhabi will
champion you know IBJJF whatever the
[ __ ] you want caught metamours and then
there's wrestling yes well once it goes
to the ground
that's another party for some guys DC
some people is he'll put you on your
back or he can get get on you and now
he's heavy on Tom's hand and I don't
know if closing me up submitting from
his back but you have problems down with
a clover he's a black belt woman yeah
from his back he's a black belt huh
interesting
that's yet to me I'd much rather see
gloves DC than glows well you know go
over after the fight looked like he
walked up to DC he did yeah it was like
man let's do this yeah DC's I come down
but I'll see a toast Amir you got so who
does who do you think Glover fights next
man I don't know I don't know is there
any word on John Jones no still they get
they push back the herring so we're just
waiting on that no I mean Glover is
right there so what you know know who
knows what they're gonna do with them
it's it's you know it's old man flan
down below there but who knows man mmm
some good fight so I got a P hard let's
pitch let's do it
must be a couple pisser's I feel so much
better there you go you're all much
better danger dog dude uh I got a bone
to pick with Bobby Lee I saw some of the
pot yet you guys did I listened to it
very funny very entertaining a little
bit of a gong show
but Bobby Lee had his feet his bare feet
all up on my chair [ __ ] you sitting like
a [ __ ] asian gargoyle I know my
[ __ ] I never like have a little
respect respect bro you fight you show
up in these ridiculous these he rolled
out of bed literally just rolling it's
like I have really high blood pressure
stroke level I'm like well there's
something I don't move hey man and then
you got Andy Dick how bad does he want
to suck my dicks get one to tell loves
you I love him loves girls way and loves
guys love girls and loves Brendon he's
amazing yeah he does he thinks you're so
hot
do me a favor look at me so you think no
let him suck your dick
you're attracted to have 52 year old men
with no shoulders he's a great guy loves
valyrian I like me but just like let him
kiss you let him drink from you guys get
done with this and just bang each other
you're stupid he's not my type - but I'm
saying that you know man I'm now you
like preening around him you did your
chest go a little puff you know I get a
little uncomfortable I'm gonna be honest
when I read the cover story he looks a
back room he's basically raping you with
his eyes yeah yeah yeah yeah he's
basting my Harvey Weinstein yeah yeah I
love it
no I'm not threatening her no not
threatening at all you just love that I
know you know it's like oh yeah he's hot
yeah I like dressed up for you he's told
me let me wear a tie for you yeah you
look great
like Andy don't primp for Brendan it's
not gonna make a difference no I'm
straight man I don't know I know but I
talk about everybody I'm not driving off
sunny shows up and he's wearing a suit
and you're like you know what you know
you know you look cute today
you're adorable all right you know what
let's do the cut to you and him in your
car too small for you can you go down
yeah
Porsches are uh nice it's a [ __ ] J night
when I was in Buffalo I looked on your
Instagram and you you laying down some
tracks you see this
no yeah Jin's cutting down a country
music song well can I hear a little
piece you play it on the Innoko you have
a you're a talented guy man
your ex managed mystery you're huge
you're creepy but you're talented you're
obviously you belong to a game five I
did some fan question that the live
shows you know and they would
his ass is chinnough serial killer
there's one the number one question we
got yes I said absolutely look at my man
this is what I hear yes
oh you got on that camera to the left at
your new camera yeah I just got
yesterday he worst it wears hats and
hoods you like cover in your head I do
you're shy I don't like it feels
comfortable yeah like cozy it feels
comfortable yeah when I put the hoodie
over it you feel secure and safe I think
ya feel safe yeah it's your safe zone I
would wear sunglasses indoors if I could
really do that you're you're an
introvert when you're so not really
anything I'm saying when you when you
are when you when you are mailing bombs
to universities no when you are ready
Bob innocent girls hands and feet and
then where the bodies are sweat suits
you are you're an introvert yeah yeah
definitely definitely introverted and
then sometimes not so but then you can
sing like Adele like a doe like your
career do you think that was a man let's
hear this song it's not like refined
annoying we don't work for [ __ ]
pension record
he wrote this now this is a Easton
Corbin it's a country song away the
keytar
you're a sensitive artist is what you
actually are you're a shy how good is
the lyrics are beautiful I thought you
wrote that God did you sing it really
well we were writing that day but then
that was like a little break and so you
you write your own songs as well yes do
you know each others who are you jamming
with his name is Trevor Yasuda he's Lana
Del Rey's engineer producer who is that
singer that's Corbin Easton Corbin
Easton Corbin what's that song called a
little more country than that I'm gonna
go listen to that yeah
what's this have chicken awful thing for
you um your weddings what uh let me see
there's a picture you and I produced fur
yeah how do you know him
I met him in engineering school can he
sing - he's not much of a singer more of
a writer but do you guys live together
he's married oh yeah and actually Lana
Del Rey went to their wedding - OH
so does he get nervous that he's gonna
get caught by his wife for having a love
for big when you guys wrote with you
write and tile to kill the next people
to help it's word bro they're both a cup
we're where did you guys do this up
point people it looks like you're gonna
hit Obama's garage what is that behind
you that's just gear audio gear it's a
little studio it says [ __ ] you [ __ ]
cover who was Jesus
oh that's someone else asking me to do a
cover of [ __ ] you [ __ ] oh oh was that
song [ __ ] you [ __ ] wheeler Walker I
remember oh yeah but you guys just
jammed out just writing I really are you
trying to come but you you're laying
down some trash trying to come out with
an album not an album just we like to
write you're in a man band I'm not a
one-man but I used to like being in
front but now I like being uh behind the
scenes you perform via satellite you
could on a satellite feed chin can't be
here he's a Boogaloo small shed in
Siberia but we're gonna Skype them in we
get the satellite see John used lay down
some tracks all weekend what's the used
to enjoy dinner is the end goal are you
trying to release some [ __ ] on iTunes
chin for sure right
the kids song I mean you hate myself for
a dollar ninety-nine thank you kiddies
make money fight her and the kids all
fighter and they go right you tie it
around the kids creepy Brian come on
Marina del Rey how come Brandon doesn't
age does he hang like a bat all night
and day Brian doesn't need does he hang
like a bat on that and day yeah yeah
yeah well leave it off faces old bodies
Young's got a dick that goes oh no bro
sounds like you just dance I feel like
you could write a good song though Chan
we could change it because this is the
thing when we get a new studio in
February and we're going live we might
have two new new a new introduction song
because it goes part kid live like it's
not lie can I pitch some this [ __ ] is
now live I think I think three of us for
real sit down and you sit up with a
guitar and we come up with a song and
for anyone and we should have little
pieces where he and I do a little chorus
like you or that's right with a fatter
and the kid something like that we could
but I mean people love that song I know
and then it's good at since it's going
live it kind of fits now which you know
since your wife alive yeah it's not live
we've been doing that a long time though
maybe we shake it up a little bit maybe
we should have the fans vote online do
you want to keep the same intro song or
should we write a new one with chin more
of a country vibe I think if we did a
song it should just be for something
else the intro so like icon everyone
loves it yeah yeah but maybe if there's
a good pork yeah we could release it too
we could release them yes just do a song
period just a song yeah and make a music
video and charge 50 bucks for the song
$50 and what featuring jay-z that's
connection of Beyonce and then yeah yeah
do a music video for it straight out
Abba Kenny that's great idea Straight
Outta loCash yeah yeah
Straight Outta advocate would you do MJ
work Lululemon
but you're going out of town soon you
gonna hear up or jump on just you don't
look great yeah I'm like I'm going to
Europe for the first time again password
passports yeah I'm going to
I'm flying to Amsterdam on the 22nd and
then that's next Tuesday
oh is that this Friday yeah I'm usually
like coming to myself for the holiday so
no
darts I'm going to Mexico when um after
Christmas - until the 2nd of January she
will talk about dark we'll talk about
out there we'll figure it out all right
Oh miss break I don't think so we'll
figure it out talk about fear all right
we're doing Mexico I don't want to talk
about that at all calling my extended
family who I love but it's gonna be
Cancun no I don't know I [ __ ] hate
you I don't know Clark son um maybe
escaping from your shitty Mexico trip
but MJ you're going to Europe and then
how you're going just all over you've
never been with three places MJ we need
a mic over there cuz it was completely
ruined yeah awkward setup I'm going to
visit my friend Paige from college
I'm visiting her and her boyfriend and
all their family in Amsterdam and then
we're spending Christmas in Amsterdam
and I'm going to Prague and then we're
gonna polish any of this crazy yeah well
I'm supposed to be amazing at Stan's
mate it's supposed to be amazing and so
stuck in my little town so I'm pretty
stoked but I'm not prepared at all I
would look I live in yoga pants it's
like always get one coat and [ __ ]
rockets buffaloes know where everything
in my closet every fund I just would
stay away from hostels and creepy dudes
I'm with like a big group it's not gonna
be a taken situation so I'm meeting one
girl hello
yeah I got a good cell phone it's not
like a to-go phone right now or anything
like that were it's weird you Bri this
is the hard part
they will take it there's Mike I'm
terrified International so I cannot use
my skill sets to help you guys get some
convention yes sir first one you know
more about but the Panthers owner is
selling the team Jerry Richardson do 81
yeah you see this B so this guy's been
accused of the waitresses the players
that and then it's come out he's used
racist lingo and he's just a bit of a
dick and then but with this what's crazy
to me so this guy he gets accused of all
this he goes oh [ __ ] it's coming out I'm
selling I'm out and then we don't look
into it but if he was anyone else or
younger or if this is a guy head of Fox
or ESP or something like that we would
roast this guy and he'd come out we'd
get all the the news on it but now he
just goes my bat I'm 81 I'm out I'm
selling 80 wants a good time to leave
anyway it's good this is what's a bummer
so you've worked your whole life in ops
he's been a dick so it's kind of good to
cut up with him but if you're him or his
family you worked your whole life
you bought the Carolina Panthers for 200
something million dollars worth their
estimate around three to four billion
dollars now so you've worked your whole
life you built this huge brands huge
company and then now you're known for
this and you gotta sell you know I'm
really really worried about social media
because you can make one mistake in
today's world and you're done beat you
so you're missing the point this dude
has a history a history it's not like oh
he told some girl she's prettier girl in
history right no no no there's County
don't I'm trying to do this all here so
there's players other owners he's
selling the team it's so bad
70 times 81 he's like I don't think it's
[ __ ] see yeah you know I mean no now
you have players on ESPN said yeah he
would use drug Tory terms towards us
you'd sexy her ass all these people they
want him out of it this isn't a social
media justice warrior thing would be
like oh he's a dick you don't sell a
company because people on social media
calling you dick I mean this isn't
Hollywood anyway yeah no he's getting
out there and everyone's celebrating
this is a good thing
yeah don't make it a twist where he's a
victim he's a bad guy that's what's
going on here like it's been known
around for leak forever that he's this
dead yeah that's why that's why I'm
trying to do an assault so the
comparison of there I'm scared social
media people get on their knee loses his
job that's a different animal yeah
different and okay
you have Ryan Clark an ESPN going who's
a
the head of the players union going he
was the worst man the way you talked us
do what he treated people
everyone wants him out and now it's time
I did he's trying to buy the Carolina
Panthers because you don't have any
african-american representatives out of
the 32 teams and now P Diddy's trying to
get a signed Kaepernick oh [ __ ] doesn't
make sense because if Cam Newton but
whatever yeah I always think about how
we are in a time man though we're like
on Instagram like you take that girl who
took money from the uber guy okay she's
18 that's a shitty thing to do she's 18
everybody does stupid things talking to
a defense lawyer his brother his
brother-in-law when he was 21 was drunk
broke into a car stole computer he got
convicted of grand larceny he's never
ever ever able to get a job again ever
he's funny he was making hot dogs in
Costco the felon about it yep he's
making cause and hot dogs in Costco he's
38 they found out about it
and they fired him he ended up dying at
40 I really worried really [ __ ]
worried now I was thinking about the
great figures in history Martin Luther
King Gandhi let's just go through it
Martin Luther King Gandhi Hemingway
Picasso and Einstein all cheated a whole
bunch on their wife Martin Luther King
only [ __ ] white prostitute yes and a
problem and maybe worse all these guys
who knows what they did and you always
say you don't want to be your heroes is
that what we want to focus on line those
guys up and whoever wants to throw the
first stone go ahead but my worry is
that we will take like one aspect of
somebody because nobody's perfect nobody
we're all centers in one way or another
you can take one aspect and when you get
exposed like that and publicly shamed it
has ramifications in a dark side I'm not
saying there aren't scumbags out there
it's Harvey Weinstein's a piece of [ __ ]
but I really worry about in general you
can be a college kid make one mistake it
lives forever on the internet and you
get the felon or it's gonna be anything
it could be that girl who stole the
money from over shitty things just by
buying I don't know about that
I'll tell you something when you steal
five bucks when you see that you go this
is what you do you go somebody people
need a job and you go and I would do the
same thing I hate to say it I'd go
you stole that five bucks that's a
shitty thing to do it's hard to get out
of my head and I'm gonna choose MJ over
you who I don't who's never done
something like that or at least I've
never seen it that's fair yeah
don't steal money from okay but but but
but it used to be that would be
something that would be somewhere and
you did be it was a misdemeanor and it
would just go away now you can see it
and now it lives forever and you are
tainted don't you think more people have
to be held accountable now though I just
like this guy people have social media
or heart moving to be harmed when say if
you don't have social media or the
others mistakes a downside but the
positive of it I feel like out always it
outweighs it because now you have this
guy who's a piece of know this what
you're saying this what you're saying
and I agree I like the idea that for the
first time women have recourse I like
the idea that for the first time men
have to be responsible to their sexual
impact I like for the first time that
there's a whisper network for women so
they don't get blacks not about just
women women no but it's also
professional athletes yeah you're
talking about power versus yes don't be
a scumbag thinking that is now I can go
I don't have to be famous I can go on
social mean go this guy's doing this to
me man yes I don't I don't it just don't
get swept into the ROI that now you have
a case that's right I all I'm saying is
that that is that part's good and like
with anything else there's also a
liability and I really wonder about like
I just worried man
maybe because I have kids one one [ __ ]
up and it's caught on camera see ya it
could be a little I disagree I think
you're over-exaggerating so like that
you are like girl'd the uber she stole
people forget about that he no because
she got harassed so badly that she had
to very still from [ __ ] uber you're
gonna take some heat haroset I promise
you she gets a job in three or four
years should be fine she's young enough
now if you commit a felony you gotta be
responsible for that you have to we
can't live in a world where forgive
everything and but I also think if you
committed a felony you should get a
second chance at a job like I feel like
after after a while like if you stole
something or like there's certain felony
times what it is gross
if your drug trafficking millions of
drugs around the world certainly does a
felony they're certain I can't have you
working on a corporation well there are
certain felonies that I like for example
if you rape or touch a kid or they I
can't have you on the street you know it
just can't have you but I'm saying that
there that that there are a lot of
people that make a mistake when they're
younger and they pay for it for the rest
of the lives where they literally can't
get a job at for sure but you always say
this the government can't make an
exception for that small project yeah
you say this yeah no but here's what I
do say to maybe there comes a time after
five ten years depending on the crime
where you were it doesn't show up on
your record where it gets sealed that's
what I like you know I'm saying yeah if
they have a good track yeah yeah that's
what I think
XANA Obama was trying to get something
like that passed and you know and that's
all nothing be great if P did about the
Carolina Panthers though Kaepernick
siding he's covered I didn't know he had
that much more really well that's how
much did it cost by a team well they're
four billion dollars three I think the
three that much well you get other
investors it'd be a team effort like
dirt Jeter bought the Marlins but it's
him and there's a bunch of partners yeah
I think he'd be a great owner I really
do that's something you'd ever want to
do would you ever want to end on a team
oh hell yeah what kind of team [ __ ] yeah
football all day really all day I said
you want to make real money you want to
own a Premier League but you would love
it because oh my god you would you just
love to be involved in well yeah
scrap run office all that players yeah I
feel like I'm too nice to run a business
like that because you'd have to you have
to be you have to fire people yeah and
I'd get close with the guys like alright
I get it man let's keep it another yeah
you would look like he's the worst
you're back darling I know for kids like
who gives a [ __ ] you always have to be a
[ __ ] to own a team and be
effective right bring a [ __ ]
yeah but still like there's a
[ __ ] but there's like Jerry
Jones who's a [ __ ] but people
love them yeah but they also know the
business I'm not cold enough hearted to
run a business like they don't think
yeah cuz you haven't been there you're
doing with human beings in there yeah
you have tell you what though 32 there's
only 32 in the world and they're all
billionaires don't you the billionaires
oh and also if your billionaire doesn't
get you access even if they're for sale
cuz all the owners
have to prove like Mark Cuban wanted to
buy it you know Donald Trump tried
buying the bills I think the entire
league went absolutely not you're not
gonna [ __ ] over the Buffalo Bills real
don't drunk tried buying the bill so the
team has to say what do you mean that
the league the owners the the
Association Association the NFLPA really
the owners i off to agree to sell to
this guy I don't return me of the most
powerful men in the world and they go
yes we all agree they vote on it Wow and
Donald Trump didn't I get the approval
vote now they went oh hell no neither
did Mark Cuban Wow
Cuban didn't do you want to buy it might
not be in the bill if you was but
they're like now we're all set on that
we don't want your crazy ass in here you
have to be a certain kind of person
that's gonna be interesting to see if
they allow an African American to own a
team because you remember a lot of
people think who's older rich kind of
boys club that they're in you know all
of them seem to think very similar even
though he's considered a rapper but even
though this Carolina Panther you know
guy owner is a piece of [ __ ] and all
that a lot of people think a lot of the
other owners are very similar because
this good ol boys club they're all older
white males well my richest [ __ ] all the
white males yeah so they're in those
club you know they're in the [ __ ]
fancy clubs and you know those they're
on the yachts and they the similar thing
and you know so they all kind of share
the similar idea so when you go
Opie did he like do we want an
african-american what do we want to wrap
her different want a guy who is depends
now now if I have to bet the over-under
that out of the 32 owners they dropped
the n-word on a daily basis I'd say 50
percent about to guess right 50 percent
really yeah I probably would now the
people go well you know we've not had an
african-american owner well that yeah
and I understand that but how many
african-americans can't afford to buy
the one of these teams billions and
billions of dollars Oprah
by Oprah Oprah oh goodness Paul Allen
Steven Ross Stan Kroenke Robert Kraft
Jerry Jones he'd con they're so rich
they're so so rich millionaires Shahid
Khan sounds like a Pakistani name he
healed though a few teams meaning he
owns uh Paul Allen's a man
Paul Allen yeah yeah you ever seen his
yachts and channel sure he's yup sure
have
I believe he does a shitload for charity
I mean you say [ __ ] low you know I'm
sure you know the division that doesn't
yeah like a lot look at him he's awesome
Shahid Khan you know I don't like that
guy clearly I don't like that guy you
know why why cuz he went sign Tim Tebow
everyone the song even if you live in
his mustache that's a man you'll [ __ ]
himself
come on Robert Kraft obviously the crab
we all know Kraft cheese for God's oh
boy yeah Kraft oh Jesus
okay I don't write row Jerry Jones with
the plastic surgery looking good looking
good if there's guy you want to go out
in the town would it be Jay Jones yes
I've seen him in Vegas have you oh my
god
suited up just the nines the most
gorgeous woman in the world
I a straight to the front yeah teri and
Kim Pegula collecting roughly 6.5
billion dollars Steve biscotti make his
money Under Armor right Robert McNair
keep going
Robert McNair pressive author blank to
me he's exactly how you'd want a guy to
look yeah that's right Tom Benson then
think if the guy who owns the Redskins
the pretty sure he owns like the real
Madrid or some [ __ ] to the show Daniel
Snyder I think it's him he's so rich but
would you want to hang out with any of
these guys I don't know them look at
that guy
my answer neck imagine them in the
locker with their little dicks I'm not
I'm not an imagined P Diddy icon casting
I imagine that P Diddy look at that guy
that's racist guys the biggest head I've
ever seen in my life
if you don't think he's dropping the
n-word as soon as Ted Ginn jr. leaves
you're easy come on man he's just told
nice piece of [ __ ] you don't know Alex
Spano good good Italian way to move the
charges to Elliott did you really mean
to all the honors John Marin ste Ali
like Jay Jones and crunchy
the Clay's our family please these nuts
come on a lot of them are Jewish they're
not denied racist look at that
what are you John Singh this daughter
hello she's oh she's a Victoria's Secret
Pink model just go heart oh okay that's
nice
Pat Bowlen I was a fan of him my son's a
complete [ __ ]
really yeah all right bunch of rich
[ __ ] white dudes look at that [ __ ]
haircut friend from look at that
[ __ ]
hold on now that's that's insane that
haircut it's not about Mark Davis with
the penis haircut
that's here's a billion dollars and they
go you heart barbering goes hey can you
give me the Dumb and Dumber bone cut
cereal I get the Jim Carrey bowl-cut
I mean don't you you're worth a billion
dollars do you not think we should
switch it up
it's [ __ ] I mean one of the kids go
dad dad seriously you can't no I look
like it did how did he make his money
that way his dad on the team that's a
Dell Davis was the owner they hand it to
hit that's it that's sound disaster keep
going
say on the exact year that guys given
died any day now yes yes William bid
well it will die any day now but hey
will I'm not trying to be a dick can we
have five billion dollars I know I'm
going the money Oh cutie woman OH
Virginia Hollis McCaskey she's 94 again
I love Dallas listen to me love that I
passed way any day now I'm gonna need
all that money on cash this way let us
dive in those gold coins i scrooge
mcduck Clark Hunt looks very friendly
man you can't be friendly when you're
running a team bro you're right man you
know what I mean you gotta make some
choices all right Rudy I'm a fan of oh
yeah Amy Adams Strunk don't you imagine
own a team just don't [ __ ] about and
bossing people around I mean that'd be
like me they'll be like mr. deeds
Martha firestorm Ford apparently I heard
a Firestone
I sure have have you you heard five some
tires well they just happen on the
Detroit Lions okay Detroit fires funny
money that's called a dynasty
make tires like brown okay Mike Mike
Mike looks in shape age is a
[ __ ]
agent foods a [ __ ] yeah they
don't mix now they don't mix don't mix
alright we can stop this that's my boy
Jed York he came to my show oh he's
friends at arc Jed Jed came to the show
I in at Cobbs we had a good time good
man - just four billion dollars
I didn't I I did ask him to join him did
you guys get in - to donate 1 billion
dollars of the final kid fun I said it
was my liver-spotted hands off my mother
I said Jed fly me anywhere please in
your private jet I'm tired of commercial
what do you say he just smiled at me he
can catch football he said no I I can
catch a football
I know you so I so I didn't say no and
if you'd asked me I would love to play
wide receiver for the 49ers I would love
that
way they're playing you might get a shot
what else you got chin Disney acquires
Fox 24 Century Fox for like 27 billion
dollars right 54 something fifty four
billion dollars that is two billion
there you go over 50 - but do you have
that much money fifty two billion
evening a billion seconds is thirty two
years that's 52 of them how crazy is
that how do you make sense that Disney
will also gain major control of who so
Disney is taking over the world do not
sleep says speaking of Hulu I went our
jag last night The Handmaid's Tale have
you seen that Oh Oh sweetie
it's done sentence December that one
Awards last I know but have you seen it
yeah everyone huh okay cuz that now I'm
one down that liked it because I found
Game of Thrones seven years late but
still I went down that rabbit of the
Hulu world ah [ __ ] - oh yeah won every
award I was watching it gone what what
did I was like huh how'd you find it
just was like I'll tell white my wife is
let's watch you think I watch it I watch
this girl thing no no no no no it's an
amazing piece of work so hold up Disney
owns Hulu they own all of Fox now but
apparently it's dead you know so they
don't have anything to do with the Fox
Sports brand so it doesn't affect the
UFC in their deal negotiations Wow how
craziest
Disney I mean you know I'm doing
Thursday how about that I don't know if
that's a good conglomerate that's he
that's too much we're all the studios
has controlled the x-men fistic foreign
Deadpool I don't like all that power in
one [ __ ] Disney does everything right
though I guess they do huh I don't know
besides those little power like that
scares me hey Eddie take it easy it's
gonna be a good time do you think run in
the world
imma take I'm hoping you guys know more
about this than I do
net neutrality was repealed so Obama's
era said that you can't commoditize or
commodify the internet right and now
that is gone so yeah so the danger would
be that certain companies who have who
provide you with Internet may say now
that they have control over it they can
do one of two things they can
essentially say look we're gonna break
it up into fast internet and slow
Internet do you want to play a premium
for fast being a rat go ahead and then
the other thing would be what if there's
an internet provider who has a service
you use but you're an area where you
have to use this service provider
well that service of our block your
access to the sites you usually do that
can only be reached with this other
provider okay now though that's the dark
side they may in the companies may
decide to do nothing because of consumer
backlash we don't really know yet and
the other thing is that if it is a fact
that this provider in particular gives
you these choices and charges you a
premium and stuff like that then it will
be it will provide opportunity for other
network providers to come in and say hey
guess what we give you everything for
one price the problem is I think they're
only about six or seven internet
providers I might be wrong
so maybe again yeah so again it's a
little thick there's a yeah there's a
lotta there's a lot of power in the
hands of you know of six five six
company it means all you single men in
your mom's basement you better download
all that porn now
now better get it going oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah it is weird yeah what else got
you this is cool you break down they'll
be anything you know what that was I
lift up for you yeah so the Pentagon
admits to actually running a
investigation on UFOs it's my mind that
costs 22 million dollars a year anything
finding any Bravo might yes hold on
right
tell keep going cheers well I'll show
you the video of one of the things that
the Navy pilot saw that sign say parking
for aliens that's silly theme oh hold on
let me see this be before you give it
alright so let me show you this video
clip I'm this bro let's turn this up
what this spicy grain soup is a nutty
tasting bar what the [ __ ] hold on it's
based on a broth a tortilla this guy I
don't want to hear about brothy spicy
green soup I saw these horses check this
out this is Navy pilots finding
something in this house Jones hey brah
Robert all right what what's the praying
man that's a big-ass moderate it's a big
old wall right watch this stuff it's a
wall
so it stops and they don't show us
anymore there's different ones that have
different footage so a lot of poll is
adding the cereal like Bigelow byah byah
a lot of it was spearheaded actually by
so Harry Reid is the Senate leader ok
the Democratic Senate leader former
we're missing some gems here being so it
says it says home up says Nick Pope we
used to run the British government UFO
project said the take-home message here
is that there's probably something out
there but we don't know what it is it's
extraordinary not the in the least
because it directly contradicts that
makes specific the Naza the US
government has issued previously when
asked about the subject and their
involvement in it precisely reflects my
own experience with intriguing but
frustrating subject so they found [ __ ]
no so hold on hold on so so Harry Reid
actually was friends with a guy who I
believe his name is Dave Bigelow a
billionaire who was really into UFO
stuff
Harry was really fascinated with it as
well so Harry and his request allocated
a certain amount of dollars for this
research in the Pentagon okay to
identify because pilots do see [ __ ] all
the time with her like listen to that I
saw a thing now there are people with
the bunk and go look there are a lot of
objects that that like I think they did
that they had a huge the Air Force did a
whole investigation on the 2,000 or
3,000 UFOs on unidentified flying
objects II in the forties fifties and
800 of them were still unexplained but
remember just because something is
unexplained doesn't mean you know but
there are there are things like this
that's pretty wild but who knows how
about that Navy pilot just said that
thing accelerated like nothing I've ever
seen yeah I hope we find aliens yeah or
it's a secret government program
yeah dude this is fascinating so it
stopped and it was rotating and there's
nothing that we know of that can do that
it's only scary if they're mean yeah
it's always scary if they're like [ __ ]
you guys we're here to take over now if
they're like what's up
we're from just planning over man things
are great here if you guys want to jump
back and forth share some ideas we got
we're probably a little further ahead in
technology on you guys let's drop some
knowledge on you earthling I can't ask a
question why are all UFO sightings so
blurry like we have great cameras and
how come that's so damn Larry that's
pretty good though
it's like nighttime right maybe maybe
our cameras can't pick it up Claire yeah
that's nice good that's in the sky
that's the Muskaan well that's uh that's
a elephant flying he's [ __ ] shooting
that's Dumbo it looks like a huge old
elephant seal fly maybe it's a bumblebee
that's how bumblebees fly well that's a
big cockroach yeah it's easy
okay salt it'd be so easy and be so cool
if we found [ __ ] aliens Yeah right in
our lifetime we do allow it as though as
human beings we'll do like data points
like we'll do um like like there'll be
two data points like you'll see that
she's something else and I will draw a
widespread conclusion as humans we
always do but we don't know but that's
cool to think also but when you this is
what makes it this gives us more ground
than Eddie Bravo or some random dude on
the youtubes going Odin there's aliens
the government's going do it when the
government goes yeah we've had a
five-year investigation we have 22,000
reports we're trying to figure out then
it you go hold up the government just
doesn't [ __ ] do this stuff just for
the [ __ ] do you know what you're saying
right now you're being that's very
intelligent because a lot of people like
who are UFO people they identify with
it's like this expression you identify
with your beliefs and you should never
identify with your beliefs the believes
not the same as values right values
abouts but police they say always like
at Pixar they always talk about this too
like they're such a good successful
company go don't don't identify with
your beliefs don't be too married to
your beliefs be more identify more with
how the way you came to your beliefs
like assess how you think that's a huge
difference like
way you came like that what was that
thing we talked about this morning it's
like Brendan and I always always check
in with each other about stuff is like
don't when you collaborate you're not
trying to be you're not trying to be
you're not trying to be better than the
person you're trying to get to what's
right you want the best prize yeah
you're not funny you're not chanting me
better than then the person it's not
about who's right it's about what's
right that's a really important thing to
keep in mind don't and it's the same
idea and I think that science would like
to certain people who are UFO people but
now when you see this [ __ ] you're like
you know what there might be some
evidence something's happen where the
government goes all right we've had
enough freaking kind of [ __ ] go on where
we need to look in this and you delegate
some money here that means something
that's makes sense right look at how
wide and huge the universe so we're a
green in the same in the universe like
it makes sense I'd be great if there
wasn't life I think it is awesome yeah I
think it's so cool as long as they don't
want to kill us in sucker but I was
gonna say I was gonna say and it's all
cool could be the apocalypse like you
never know right like it's like whoo I'm
talking about sexual harassment arles
all said hey guess what you got some
real problems but you think that you
think everyone seems a problem
no we have a gun that will I just gotta
fight whites out everybody we have that
technology I see but I think humans are
wired to think of the worst when we
think of aliens because we want to
protect ourselves same as cavemen and
that's why we're scared the dark because
the the big you know things I would need
us are in the dark and we're scared of
all that stuff so we're wired to think
the worst and things for our protection
survive but I think that we might be
wrong and they're awesome and they're
like what's all baby like we're just
making sure you guys aren't gonna kill
us you guys we're literally a hop skip
jump away we got technology get there
it's pretty awesome yes we frigid as all
like is gonna cancer everybody and old
age that's right we didn't read a
newspaper
you got self cancer oh yeah and we can
stop aging whenever you want man it's
just a simple pill cheap as [ __ ] hey
Brian you want to be taller how big of a
dick do you want
I'll come out to little crazy but why
not and our ratio six to one girls the
gals get older or 40 we kill oh yeah
like hey aliens Jesus aliens oh my god
I'm just saying I think we got the wrong
picture I think they're gonna be [ __ ]
awesome they're actually gonna help us I
think they're the one
that are gonna get us to evolved another
level I'm also a positive person I could
be completely here my name have my
friend you your friend says something
like oh you're killing my buddy my buddy
was sketching young man he's from
England and we're all like talk and
stuff like that my buddy's like my
girlfriend we're all get him advice on
this girlfriend she's such a pain they
asked it's like I know dude well you got
to do this and my funny he's he's
sketching any fungus cut her head off my
this is so cool though chin I'm excited
about aliens tonight I get a visit and I
just disappeared forever tonight I get
home visit the probe in his robe it's
like Mars wrong is wrong Bannock minute
right you don't know that movie they
just stick their fingers in your butt
they have long fingers what else you get
chin I think we're completely off on
aliens though this is bad but it just
happened this morning the Amtrak that
derailed you talking about a veteran of
train rides an Amtrak so I'd like to
dive in on this one if you've got mine
yep how'd it get off track though it's
on a goddamn rail was there like a log
there's Tony pictures oh [ __ ] it was
going the right I mean it was going too
full almost a full I'm not miles per
hour allowed but this is the first time
they had 78 people full on that train
eight people dead do is update people
night 86 people 77 and it fell off the
tracks
yep because it's too heavy they don't
they have to still invest in my hair
object they don't know how terrifying oh
all the ways to go that's crazy that's
what it looks like why that's so [ __ ]
I'm not taking the train important no
one on the ground they said no one got
or no one died on the ground it was only
the people on the train in the oh yeah
yeah well so not getting higher ground
from it hitting it good god man what a
terrible way to go oh I'd rather be
abducted by aliens that's a bummer man
what else you got alright this very
famous soccer player went in blackface
he has like 4.9 million followers and he
actually did this for an 80s party and
he thought I'd be okay
hear me out here this that bad give us
some perspective this that bad it's not
he's not racist I don't think it's
raised so he's supposed to be like
Harlem Globetrotter where they're all
black he's that's what that was one of
his things he goes it's not what's wrong
with you I was a fan of the house
sellable yeah I get it he's not he's not
mocking that the Harlem Globetrotters
were black and they looked funny he's
going man I don't be a Harlem
Globetrotter they're iconic
they're all black I'm gonna buy the
Jersey but he doesn't what he's not a
product that he's French or something in
this country when you were in blackface
there's a racist pass to that because
you know yeah the characters are made
fun of back in the day blackface is what
they made fun of african-americans I get
all that now I don't think this guy is
racist and I don't think I think I don't
you get beat up any party walked into in
America for this but probably more by
white people than black people - mm-hmm
that's the other thing I bet you most of
the venom comes from fellow White's cute
kid he has to know about that though
right
you've gotta know not necessarily really
he's European they don't have a history
of that that's different mmm so I think
that it was a funny a goofy looks
ridiculous Harlem Globetrotters hey I'm
this on that and then he [ __ ] up I
don't think he's raised yeah and I'm
glad you said that
can you grab see that say vomiting fungi
could be a solution to plastics to lemma
Oh a nevermind yeah they're breaking out
plastic with mushrooms you know I don't
think he's racist at all I just think
he'd probably should know that you can't
do that people will get people don't
wanna give that famous yes now I want to
wear a barrette like that I wish I had
hair where I had to wanna play them
primarily to do that that was it yeah I
think that's a that's a good chin thanks
man man that is a bummer
good podcast a buddy of the fun one
brother I'm also don't touch my door
serious serious on it kettlebell work
last night did you
I was tired and I was like you know what
I'm gonna swing a kettlebell for a while
late at night wait I mean now five five
or six I didn't want to once I got going
brother dude how about I was training
this morning with
Glenn from boxing man who I train with
all the goddamn time home it's before we
started us check this out and this feat
this band Goldfinger I he works out the
lead singer they're performing from
thousands of people I'm like yeah cool
manse Goldfinger he was no keep watch it
and he goes all the way from England
plan Holmes and Glenn come sprinting out
on the stage and sings the verse no yeah
he's like yeah and then I'm laughing
what the ring is that he sings the whole
verse and they're seeing together he's
rocking out he's doing this and then
Glenn look to the crown goes haha and
jumps into the crowd I like was anyone
else Krauts there's gold is gold finger
at Hard Rock like punk rock okay is
there footage of it here
uh he might put on his Facebook or yeah
I don't know where it was hilarious it'd
be Glenn it'd be Glenn Holmes Facebook
whose hilarious though that's so funny
to me unless it was anyone else crowd
surfing is now how great how do you know
I'm gonna catch you dude Harry Connick
jr. pulled me up on on stage in front of
5,000 people and San Diego and asked me
to say a couple words but you're a
singer I mean you're a performer so
don't learn that trainer but let Kelly
handled this
what's his facebook is that the way you
spoke with hol ma CMEs it's usually Glen
homes la owned one end see similar names
I'll one out okay see Cesar says similar
names below the search by name click on
that one typing Glen homes LA to it
right now it's not that easy man yeah
there I'll find it here you know just
just forget it it's over the height is
gone the hype is gone you get some two
ends oh there you go dammit Brennan well
I'll [ __ ] I mean hey man he just
trained on us bells whole name do you
think it's one yeah did he post it yeah
okay he comes to the hype video
they take it off he's Travis Barker's
head trainer awesome yeah mmm the money
got taken off for a violation of
infraction or something
okay that's a lot of videos unless
videos Glenmore training um sweet man
cool
well be it stop were you gonna be men
well I mean I would say none of our teen
yeah I got some time say knees I loves a
nice Nashville is a knees then Columbus
funny bone where you were great club
spot my birthday January 25th 26 out of
D one that really hurts me that I'm 51
you're over the hill it's out so you're
on the bet you like middle back nine
your back nine once you have fifty went
back again less cuz we're gonna Sumer
living 100 all night towards the battle
aged yeah you fully and you dived into
the middle aged brother where am I
what's next for me man oh I'm in
Portland January 11th through the 13th
at helium in Portland I'm there the
whole weekend and then the big old one
January 19th I'm at the Wilbur theater
in Boston there are less than 20 tickets
left to that bit just sold out which is
insane we can forward to that so it goes
Portland
11th through 13th January I'm at the
Wilbur 19th and then the I just
announced a bunch of dates you and I are
in Vancouver together okay we're in
March I was just for last comic tour I'm
doing my own set there and then me and
Bryan would go finding the kid that's
Vancouver and then Denver February 1st I
might be fairy second I'm at Denver at
the comedy like Tom Hardy Comedy Works
downtown great coming home Denver baby
and coming home in Denver in some ways
the best maybe the best club can I sing
the P Diddy song huh yep I'm coming home
tell the world I'm coming home Denver
I'm coming you're just a star Brian and
myself t fat K dot car
oh she liked that that's really good
this is the fired kid we're out